Brown plan to do and what Cameron
implemented was that chipping away at
the capital budgets so that they could
pour the money into things like Health
pensions and Welfare the politically
sensitive and popular areas that people
always want more money for it's
essentially short-termism at its worst
because it's it's bribing voters not
telling them about the Investments that
need to be made down the road and the
irony as I point out in the piece is
that I think a lot of these politicians
probably thought well I'll be long gone
by the time that these things start to
break down and that's somewhat true but
the Tory government's still here and 13
years on Rishi sunak is having to
explain why these decisions weren't made
more than a decade ago because the
Tories are still in charge and had they
done some of those crucial Investments
and reprioritized funding and had
tougher conversations with the public
then where she's seen that could in
theory be taking credit right now for
new infrastructure programs for better
schools instead he's having to defend
why the country's falling apart